[Music]
[Applause]
he's the popular Ross Tucker Westwood
One CBS Sports NFL college football
analyst and he hosts the Ross Tucker
football podcast he'll also be on the
call Thursday night for the Bears and
the commanders on Westwood One Ross good
morning how are you morning Dan doing
fantastic how are you man well we're
good we're just trying to figure out how
bad things are let's start with the
Giants and is this a bump in the road or
is this a pothole that can't be filled
this year
uh probably a pothole that can't be
filled this year I am a little curious
to see how they look when they get their
two best offensive players back I mean
they have a pro bowl left tackle on
Andrew Thomas
who does make a significant difference
for them up front and they just I mean
Dan I don't feel like they've ever given
Daniel Jones good receivers I mean I'm
watching last night Isaiah Hodgins and
Paris Campbell they are a team it's
funny because we always have these
debates about running backs and how
important they are I got news for you
saquon Barkley is really important to
the Giants because he's by far their
most talented skill position player
their most explosive player and I think
he gives Daniel Jones some easy
completions because they don't have a
very good receiving core okay but they
do have Waller he was supposed to be a
Difference Maker this is a team that
went to the playoffs they won a playoff
game Barkley banged up again but that
offensive line I don't know if one
offensive lineman coming back is going
to cover up all those blemishes here are
they are they going to be the worst team
in their division
yeah I think they are
um which is surprising to me you know a
lot of people thought the Giants would
take a big step back from last year I
thought they'd be about what they were I
actually thought you know year two for
Daniel Jones in that system with Brian
dabel I thought he would build upon what
he did last year I was okay with the
Giants giving him that contract I think
the thought process was hey you know he
played really well in the second half of
the year he played awesome in a road
playoff game that we won now he'll be
second year in the system we'll get him
some better weapons he'll be even better
and it just not has not happened so far
at all not even close okay could you see
a scenario where the Giants are out of
it and then all of a sudden Waller would
be available take one Barkley may be
available to trade
you know the the trade deadline still
pretty early in the NFL you know it's
Halloween this year they they keep
pushing it back it's interesting Dan
because if you got to like mid November
or even more like baseball like late
November I feel like you'd see more
trades like that yeah but that's tough
to do in the NFL when you still have two
months left that's a lot of football to
be played I mean you're talking about
these teams still playing nine games but
do you think the NFL doesn't want that
that they don't want teams to be giving
up earlier or you're renting player I'm
not sure what the logic would be as to
why you have a trade deadline that's not
you know halfway deeper through the
season
I think that they always had the fear
Dan that it would that teams would the
later it goes the teams would it would
give the impression that teams were
giving up on the season and the NFL's
very sensitive to that and maybe
rightfully so they really don't like
when people talk or believe that a team
is tanking for a draft pick you know
what the NFL believes in is Any Given
Sunday anybody can win look the
Cardinals beat the Cowboys by double
digits that's really what they want to
hang their hat on I think is the
competitiveness of every game it is
interesting though because it's like the
total polar opposite I feel like Dan of
like basketball where basketball so much
of the conversation is the transactions
that are made and the moves and the guy
and it feels like the the the the NFL
doesn't want to be about that other than
like the draft and free agency they
don't want the season to be about
anything other than the season not teams
and the transactions and roster moves
they're making talking to Ross Tucker
Westwood one and CBS Sports NFL and
college football analyst former NFL
offensive lineman I started the show
because there was I had this moment last
night I'm watching the game and I'm
watching Pete Carroll on the sidelines
he's 72. he's the youngest 72 year old
guy that you probably would ever be
around
and I wondered you got Belichick who
might be on the hot seat and looks like
maybe the game is passing him by and
what you know he did before and you
can't do it now
but here's Pete Carroll refreshed had a
rebuild on that team at 70 traded away
if you know potential future Hall of
Fame quarterback
and then I started thinking about Deion
Sanders with the spirit that he has with
Colorado is it's a college type spirit
that Pete Carroll still has that he took
from USC to Seattle and I I was
wondering Dion could do that
Dion could do what Pete Carroll's doing
from the standpoint of that enthusiasm
that energy that's there and I don't
know why I just had that connection
between those two the oldest coach in
the NFL and then Dion's impact in
college football and then Bill Belichick
is sort of you know dangling in limbo
here in New England
you know Dan there's several awesome
topics off of that that statement by you
number one
um is that I really feel like with every
passing year the positivity of Pete
Carroll right the the the the hey has
everybody's back and the encouragement
that reinforcement that plays much
better with these young guys than than
the negative reinforcement in New
England I I truly believe that that that
that that makes a big difference in
terms of the motivation I don't think
that the negative reinforcement in New
England is as powerful or as impactful
as it used to be the other thing is Dan
I don't know if I ever really thought of
this so you just said it right
if they don't throw that pass against
New England in 2014 and they hand the
ball to Marshawn Lynch and they win that
game okay and Pete Carroll has multiple
national championships and multiple
Super Bowls
has anybody else ever done that and as
we keep talking about him and the
success he's having again now where does
Pete Carroll then stack up because Saban
has been unbelievable in college didn't
really do it in the NFL now Belichick's
never really been in college but also
Belichick's never really done it with
anybody other than Tom Brady I just
think that Pete Carroll especially if he
had won that second Super Bowl not that
you have to but if he had two super
bowls with I don't know what did he get
in college two or three that would put
him in a really unique category and he'd
have a heck of an argument when you
start talking about the best coaches
ever
if you had you know we looked at
football the way basketball looks at
basketball it's the Basketball Hall of
Fame it's the football if they did the
Football Hall of Fame as opposed to the
Pro Football Hall of Fame then maybe
you'd be looking at Pete Carroll
differently that you know now his status
or his place in history changes because
what he did in college and what he did
and has done in the NFL you get two
national titles you won a Super Bowl you
were literally on the doorstep of a a
second one there but at 72
um I mean it's it's remarkable and you
know they're not going to win that
division but they're going to be a
playoff team wild card team probably he
brought in Geno Smith they draft well
they got rid of Russell Wilson they got
an unbelievable Hall back from Denver
um and you know Pete and John Schneider
have done a a wonderful job
and and I think Dan last year might have
been his finest coaching job I mean
going into the year when you told me
they were going to have two rookies
starting an offensive tackle and Geno
Smith the quarterback it was like it was
like it was like Top Gun like you're
gonna do what
and I I thought they might be the worst
team in the league and they made the
play
I mean that was really really impressive
obviously what he did with Russell
Wilson and Legion to boom and that stuff
was impressive but I don't know that
there was a better coaching job that
Pete Carroll's done than last year
getting that Seattle Team into the
postseason
I said this yesterday would Bill
Belichick the GM fire Bill Belichick the
coach
uh
uh oh but Bill Belichick the head coach
would fire Bill Belichick at GM
if it worked that way listen Dan they're
gonna have to do something right like I
don't know what's going to be but you
know it's really interesting
they are victims of their own success I
have a bunch of friends better Patriots
fans and the real issue isn't that and
Seton can talk about this but the real
issue isn't that they're one in three or
whatever the real issue is
there's not really any path right now
for them to get back to to being a
championship caliber team like what when
you're looking at the Patriots what are
you saying well at least we have this or
we have that or if we do this or we do
that there's nothing right now there's
nothing right now that gives you any
hope that they can be back to being a
Super Bowl Contender and after 20 years
of it was super bowl or bust these
people aren't okay Dan with seven wins
eight wins oh it was a pretty good year
you know we went nine and eight we had a
winning season they're very spoiled and
rightfully so and so they're in a really
tough spot here because once your fans
start to become apathetic or once your
fans feel like they don't have hope
that's a problem
all right you're going to be on the call
the Bears commanders on Thursday night
there's a bet in place for meat Friday
because the Bears and Broncos just
played Paulie is a Bears fan Francia
Broncos fan and the loser doesn't get to
take part in meet Friday until his team
wins again so Paulie lost on Sunday but
he's got an out with this game on
Thursday if the Bears beat the
commanders then meet Friday is restored
for Pauling
who do you have winning Thursday night
with the commanders and the bears with
meat Friday at stake oh man I I forgot
that meat Friday was at stake that had
to be brutal for paulions because I know
Paulie I'm pretty sure Paulie invented
meat Friday so that's got to be killing
him I I like the commanders I know you
know you're supposed to say that the
Bears are winless and they're going to
win one of these and maybe a short week
against the commanders team that just
went to overtime against the Eagles
but I don't know then I'm actually
pretty impressed by the commanders
watching them against the Eagles on
Sunday you know I've had several
quarterbacks tell me over the years you
don't really know about a guy
until they have a terrible game Throw
three or four picks their team loses and
how they bounce back from that
well if that's the case then the the
commanders might have their quarterback
because Sam Howell was terrible against
the bills four picks they lose by 30
points he goes into Philadelphia and
completes over 70 of his passes
including that drive all the way down
the field which probably would have been
a game-winning drive if Ron Rivera went
for two but that's a whole other
conversation I think Hal might be the
real deal and I think the commanders win
that game I mean the Bears are just a
mess right now the chase Claypool thing
the defensive coordinator I mean they're
like the Bad News Bears right now okay
but they're probably going to end up
with two of the top
four picks in the draft
they got right now Carolina's pick they
got their pick yeah right now would be
the top two picks yeah which is funny
because unlike the Patriots which is so
bizarre right the bears actually have
hope in that regard well at least we're
gonna have the top two picks but that's
also Dan what they said last year last
year like hey Fields looks good but keep
losing so we get the number one pick
well got Fields we'll trade the number
one pick for a Kings Ransom then the
next year's well well we're at the next
year now and they haven't won a game yet
feel doesn't look like the guy so it
were how many years in a row are you
going to do this if you're the bear is
this like the Sixers and we're trusting
the process of getting the number one
pick every year and eventually somehow
will be good
we were just uh talking about movies the
the movie Rounders I like I just hate
John malkovich's accent when he's KGB
paid that men his meniere
um we were going to try to guess what
one of your favorite movies is of all
time okay we each get one guess all
right Todd
airplane
okay
Seton Animal House
all right Marvin
Shawshank Redemption oh holy I'm so sure
of one of them I'm taking it off the
board the program I mean my pick will be
I would bet I would bet a week's pay
that it was in Ross's top three that he
put together before I better we expand
it um my guess would be old school
because of Ross's age okay I'm gonna go
Gladiator
I forgot about Gladiator I love
Gladiator first of all Holly knows me
like a book I mean starting defense yeah
did I watch that did I watch that movie
the night before two days started ever
since I was 14 years old yes yes I did
watch the program every year
um by the way um the worst guess by far
was fritzy with airplane come on I'm 44
years old I mean come on
um old school was an excellent guess
that is up there for sure
um I can't believe this I must have said
it on the show before but my number one
favorite movie ever is Shawshank
Redemption ah Marvin Marvin I must have
said that someone there's no way Marvin
just pulled that out of nowhere
Marvin it's everybody's favorite movie
it's not mine
it's a great movie it's a great guess
okay I'll give you I'll give you a
couple more before I forget okay
um Rocky IV I'm in that movie
single-handedly ended the Cold War
you've heard of it Rocky IV okay and
then very underrated comedy I laughed
multiple times a week just thinking
about it Kingpin with Bill Murray oh
unbelievable
Kingpin wasn't that shot in Pennsylvania
of course it was okay I thought yes
eastern Pennsylvania like Scranton and
Wilkes-Barre yeah
um for sure I I would say it was tough
for me for the comedy between old school
and
um Wedding Crashers okay and then in
terms of a sports movie I really like
Hoosiers believe it or not like I'm a
big Hoosiers guy no you're an underdog
kind of guy yes I am yeah and we have
Sylvester Stallone in studio uh who
knows uh Rocky IV quite well
uh tomorrow man I can't I can't do this
tomorrow there is there is no tomorrow
even though it's Rocky three there is no
tomorrow
that could have been a little bit better
and you could change
Todd you had the wrong movie that was
Rocky three before
sorry
okay I'm convinced that if you had the
Rocky IV soundtrack playing while I got
in the ring with like the heavyweight
champ of the UFC or boxing that I would
win that fight as long as like the
training montage or Eye of the Tiger is
on in the speakers yeah of the Arena
from Rocky IV I I will beat anybody in a
fight just make sure it's really loud
good to talk to you have fun on Thursday
night will do see you guys that's Ross
Tucker
he'll be on the call Thursday night
Bears commanders on Westwood One